JOHANNDU TOIT: So
welcome, everyone,
to the long-awaited
second episode.
So just real quick--
we're joined today
by a few Googlers and GDEs.
So, first off, what are GDEs?
It's the local-- there are four
or five of us in the chat room
right now.
So it's local people
with local expertise
helping on some Google Techs.
If you are using
it in your startup,
we're here to listen
and maybe help.
So next up, the
actual show is-- we're
trying to keep it monthly,
and that's the second one.
We're trying.
And then we're
going to see if we
can make this downloadable
MP3s, so anyone can [INAUDIBLE]
listen to it if you can't
get to the video today.
And the live
Hangouts-- so if you're
interested in
joining the Hangouts,
maybe you have something
to share or something
to show at the end
of the show, we're
going to give you a form to sign
up, give feedback, and join us.
So off to Hiren.
HIREN PATEL: Hi, everyone.
So to introduce the
panel here today for you,
we have an invasion of Cloud
GDGs, Google Developer Experts.
And they are Johanndu
Toit, sitting
next to me, Dale Humby--
who's sitting on the Hangout
if you want to just wave,
hi-- Kenneth Kinyanjui who
is sitting in Nairobi joining
us, and myself, Hiren Patel.
We also have Mercy Orangi who
is the developer ecosystems
community manager for
sub-Saharan Africa Google,
if you just want
to wave as well.
So what are we
talking about today?
The theme for today is
WordPress on App Engine.
WordPress is a really
popular web framework,
and Google App Engine is
a highly scalable Platform
as a Service offered by Google.
And we're talking
about combining
the two in running your
WordPress web application
on a highly scalable platform.
So why is it a good
time to do this?
Well, one of the reasons is that
the PHP runtime for Google App
Engine has just become
generally available.
And this means
it's deemed stable,
completely supported, backed
by a service level agreement,
and so on.
It's a good time to use PHP in
general on Google App Engine.
So a schedule for today
looks as follows--
we're going to have a
small [? bit ?] of notes
from our spotlight
speaker, who's Mercy.
We're then going to have Kenneth
introduce the main topic for 10
minutes, talking about
building your WordPress
project on Google App Engine.
We'll then have a Q&A
session for five minutes.
So if you have any questions,
please pop them into the Q&A,
so we have enabled the
Q&A app for the Hangout.
If you're on the
Hangout on [INAUDIBLE]
you should see the
Q&A app, and you
should be able to ask
your questions there.
You can also ask your questions
on the Google+ [? Invent ?]
or this page, as well as the
Google+ Google Developers
Africa community.
So post your questions
to these three mediums,
and we will field
them and answer them
at the end of main session.
And then we'll have a closing
and wrap-up for five minutes
or so.
So to kick things off, I'm going
to hand over to our spotlight
speaker, Mercy.
JOHANNDU TOIT: So we've got
Mercy on the channel, who
you might not recognize.
I don't know if you've waved
yet, Mercy, to show you.
MALE SPEAKER: Here we are.
JOHANNDU TOIT: So Mercy-- so
elevator pitch, who are you?
Where are you based?
What are you doing?
MERCY ORANGI: All right.
So, first off, thanks very much
for having me on your show.
It's a great
privilege, I must say.
So my name is Mercy Orangi.
I'm the developer ecosystems
committee manager,
in [INAUDIBLE],
sub-Saharan Africa,
in our [INAUDIBLE] team
called the Developer
Relations at Google.
So that's me.
Previously, I was working at a
local insurance asset managers
bank.
And I got to work on
various in-house systems,
in terms of development
and automation.
And the greatest project
for me when I was there
was one that turned out to
[INAUDIBLE] into creating
the investments platform
with the National Integrated
[INAUDIBLE] Registration
System, a database that
is owned by the government.
This got to cut the
processing overhead
by 18%, which was a really
cool thing for the bank.
I also used to
manage and organize
activities for GDG Nairobi--
that's Google Developer Groups
Nairobi.
So things to do with monthly
meet-ups, [INAUDIBLE],
outreach programs, like computer
science for high schools, etc.
So that's on the GDG.
So coming into Google,
this offered me
a platform to engage more
with developer communities
on activities and the whole
thing, in my role currently.
So, yeah, that's me.
And thank you very
much for having me.
JOHANNDU TOIT: Awesome.
So at Google, you're currently
running the Launchpad programs,
is that correct?
MERCY ORANGI: Yeah,
so that's true.
My current focus is on
the Launchpad program.
So this is Google's program
that we use to get in touch
and try and engage with
startups in the region.
So, globally, but I handle
the regions of Saharan Africa.
So start-ups get to apply and,
if accepted into the program,
then they get to
[INAUDIBLE] a few
of the benefits that you them.
A few being-- a few of them,
an example being cloud credit.
We have Firebase
also, currently,
one-on-one testing and
time with our experts
to actually critique the apps.
So there's a lot that
startups in the region
can leverage on once on
the Launchpad program.
Yeah.
JOHANNDU TOIT: Awesome.
So anyone can join
from across Africa?
They can just go sign up?
MERCY ORANGI: Exactly.
So that's true.
Anyone-- anyone,
strictly anyone can
apply, provided
you've got a startup,
and it's something that
you want to start or scale,
depending on whatever stage
you are in your startup.
Anyone can apply and get
to leverage the benefits
if accepted onto the program.
So, if you want to apply, the
application is open online.
Just search for
developers.google.com/startups--
that's the URL-- and you're
going to see a button where you
can apply.
JOHANNDU TOIT: We'll
get Mercy to post a link
to anyone that wants to apply.
And so, Mercy, just last
things-- interesting events
we should look out for?
What's happening?
MERCY ORANGI: Sure thing.
So there's one that is
currently in the pipeline.
This is GDS.
In full, that's Google
Developer Summit.
So they're doing the first
of its kind in the region.
And it will be held in three
cities in the region-- that's
Lagos, Nairobi, and Cape Town.
Being the first in the
region, we actually
have a lot of expectation
from developers.
We'd like you to apply and come.
It's a technical event
focused on lead developers,
lead designers,
CTOs and the likes.
So feel free to apply and
shortlisted candidates
will be contacted
in early August
to give them much
more in-depth info
about the-- about the summit.
So for you to apply just go
online and search for Google
Developer Summit Sub-Saharan
Africa, you'll see the website.
But, better yet, go to Google+,
search for Google Africa--
the page-- and you will
see a post that they made.
And feel free to apply.
JOHANNDU TOIT: Awesome,
thank you very much.
We know you a bit better now.
MERCY ORANGI: Sure.
Thanks a lot for having me,
it's actually a pleasure.
JOHANNDU TOIT: So now off
to our remaining topic.
Kenneth, sitting next to
her, is going to teach us
how to build a schedule block.
I'm interested.
It's all yours, Kenneth.
KENNETH KINYANJUI: Hey.
Hey, Africa.
So today I'm going
to show you how
to deploy Your WordPress
website on a Google App
Engine in steps.
So, just to tell
you about WordPress,
it's actually a free and open
source CMS-based platform,
that's actually based
on a PHP in MySQL.
The magic lies between--
in its plug-in architecture
and template system.
So it's very easy for you to
spin up your WordPress site
in a matter of hours,
and deploy it online.
So it's actually powering 23%
of the top 10 million websites
on the web.
Today I'm going to show you why
Google App Engine and WordPress
should be friends, and
where-- how do they meet?
And why should you deploy
your WordPress on App Engine?
So App Engine is actually
Google's Platform as a Service.
And it allows you to
run your WordPress site,
or your applications
that you build then
deploy on App Engine, or
Google's infrastructure.
And one of the magics
in it, it actually
allows you to have
automatic scaling.
You don't need to have
a server system admin.
So Google App Engine handles
most of those sys admin
tasks for you.
It's actually very easy to
integrate with other Google
Platform services that actually
enhance your application.
So today-- this is
what we'll be building.
This is a screenshot
of a WordPress site
that's actually been deployed
on Google App Engine.
In the next couple of
minutes I'll show you--
I'll be covering the following--
What do you actually require
to do the deployment?
How do you actually set up a
Google Cloud Platform Project?
Which config files
do you need to edit?
How do you run it locally?
And how do you actually
share it with the world
by putting it up on App Engine?
And I'll give you
tips and tricks.
So let's start.
Basically you need a PHP SDK
server for Google App Engine.
You also need a
local MySQL server
on your local environment and
also on your host environment.
So in this case on your host
environment you use Cloud SQL.
You also need a Google
Cloud Platform account.
So, setting up a project
on Google App Engine.
So what you need to do is
just go to cloud.google.com.
And you'll actually initially
sign in on your Google+.
You'll actually see
a button where I've
circled right in my console.
This should be your
friend, especially when
you're trying to deploy.
So when you hit that guy,
you'll actually see a pop-up
where you can actually-- you'll
see the existing projects that
are there on your Google
Cloud Platform account.
So you need to
"start a new project"
and when you start
a new project,
you'll give it a project name.
So in this case we'll give
ours Wordpress iPhone 2000.
You'll also need to
define the data center
where your app will live.
In this case, since my app
is in Kenya, or in Africa,
but most of my
users are in-- are
coming from Kenya and
sub-Saharan Africa.
So when [INAUDIBLE] data
center, [INAUDIBLE] make sense,
it's actually the
European data center.
So you actually go
to Advanced Options
and actually select the
European data center.
So remember, everything
that you will create
will have to live
in this data center.
So once you hit that
guy, you actually
see [INAUDIBLE] the process of
your instance being created.
And that should show
that things are going OK.
So after this
[INAUDIBLE], you need
to remember that was the
first thing, creating a cloud
platform account.
So the next thing will be
downloading the Google App
Engine PHP SDK from the
Google Cloud platform.
And then install--
download it and actually
follow the install instructions
just directly under that.
So there are a couple
of tasks that we'll do
on the Cloud Platform account.
We'll actually create Google
Cloud Storage buckets,
which is very important.
We'll also create a
Cloud SQL instance,
and also download the WordPress
on Google App Engine Starter
Kit.
So the first thing is actually
hitting the Compute option.
And you'll actually see
App Engine, Compute Engine,
and [INAUDIBLE] Engine.
So we are very most
interested with App Engine.
So after that, so you know that
you're dealing with App Engine,
you need to create a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
So App Engine has this--
it's a Platform as a Service,
so it doesn't allow
you to actually write
on its file system.
So you'll actually need
to come up with a way
to upload your media files.
So that's why we need a
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
And we'll actually create one.
So the process of creating
one, we'll give it a name.
So in this case we'll
give it WordPress on GAE.
And then we'll actually
go to Advanced Options
and give it-- we'll actually
put it in the data center
European Union,
because remember we
started-- we put our app engine
up on the European data center.
The next thing will be
creating a Cloud SQL instance.
So remember, one of the
requirements is a MySQL server,
and when your app
is on the cloud,
we'll actually need an
online instance of MySQL
running-- supporting your app.
So in this case,
we'll use Cloud SQL,
which is one of the services
that's offered on Google Cloud
Platform.
So creating an instance is
very easy, but remember,
your database name has to be
called-- your database instance
has to be called WordPress.
So you'll actually give
it-- create a Cloud SQL
instance with your project ID
being WordPress and GAE_2000,
and its instance
name is WordPress.
And remember, the data
center has to be in Europe.
So once you've created
a Cloud SQL instance,
this should show
up showing that you
have a successful
installation of setting up.
Now, the next final
step will actually
be, now that that step,
which is [INAUDIBLE],
is actually downloading
the Google App Engine PHP
starter project.
So a couple of Googlers have
been maintaining this project
and making it up to
date, and making it easy
for you to deploy WordPress
sites on Google App Engine
infrastructure.
So once you download the-- once
you download your App Engine
files for your various
platforms, be it Mac,
be it Linux, or Windows,
we need to unzip the file.
And once you unzip
the file, you'll
have a couple of
interesting, important files
that will show up.
So one important app in
any App Engine application
is the app.yaml
file, whic is used
to configure the application.
The next most important
file is actually
the wp-config file, which
is very key in configuring
your WordPress instance.
So in this case,
we're configuring
two GAEs, Wordpress,
and Google App Engine.
So you need to edit
these config files.
And the first one,
as you mentioned,
will be the WordPress
config file, wp-config.php.
And you'll be
interested in two GAEs.
So you'll be interested
in the first GAE
being the local environment
and the local app engine cloud
environment.
So there are two arrows, and the
first arrow shows a Cloud SQL,
and you have to replace
your project ID there.
And you'll also-- the second
one actually configures
your local [INAUDIBLE] with
your root password and the MySQL
root password.
So if you do it
successfully, so you
should have Cloud SQL,
WordPress-2000, and WordPress.
So this shows you
that you have already
configured your wp-config file
to notice your app engine app
instance.
The next thing will be to
configure your app.yaml file.
And you need to change
your project ID.
So the reason for
this is when you're
deploying your app on
the Google App Engine,
and you're pushing it
from local to the cloud,
this is the part that
the app engine will
look for and actually
configure your project.
So you need to replace
that with your project ID.
And once you do that, you have
[INAUDIBLE] and your project
ID is now WordPress GAE 2000.
So the first thing--
the most important thing
now is running your
WordPress locally.
You need to know, is it working?
And so in the
beginning I told you
about starting a-- creating
a WordPress database.
So you'll go to MySQL and
create a Wordpress-- you create
a database named WordPress_db.
So this goes into
your local storage,
and actually matches
to your App Engine app.
So if you want to run your
app on Mac or Windows,
you can use the terminal
or use the launcher.
So another important
thing to note
is that on Mac and
Windows, the SDK comes
with its PHP binaries bundled.
And just running the app is
just a push of a button away.
So you just need
to run [INAUDIBLE],
and you need your WordPress
on GAE 2000 directory.
So-- but if it's
on Linux, since you
have to use your
own PHP binaries,
I actually prefer to copy
a script that's there.
So we give-- you do as you
do it on Mac or Windows,
and you actually give it the
next couple of-- the location
to where your PHP binaries
are installed in your system.
So once you do that, you should
actually run App Engine locally
and install the PHP-- and
install [INAUDIBLE] show up,
and you'll now be able to
install-- work with WordPress
and your App Engine locally.
So the most important
thing now is
you have App Engine running
locally in the local machine,
but it doesn't make
sense if you're
uploading on your laptop.
So you need to push it online.
So we need to deploy it.
And deploying is very
easy on Google App Engine.
It's just a button away.
So you actually-- now,
remember we set up our project.
So actually now, we do not use
[INAUDIBLE] the [INAUDIBLE],
and then give a command
update, and give your WordPress
on GAE 2000 update.
And once you give
that command, it
should actually trigger
a deployment command
and start deploying
the app automatically.
So just like you did
on your local database,
you'll need to also set up your
WordPress_db inside your Cloud
SQL.
So to do that easily, you just
run Google_SQL.pui and give it
your Cloud SQL instance.
So in this case, we'll give
it WordPress on GAE-2000,
and then the name of-- the
exact name of WordPress.
So giving it that actually
automatically triggers
an [INAUDIBLE]
authentication [INAUDIBLE].
So naturally it will
direct you to your browser,
and when you accept, you'll be
able to access your Cloud SQL
instance.
So you'll actually be
[INAUDIBLE] in that,
and you'll actually now create
a database, WordPress_db.
So that's the most
important-- that's
what App Engine will be
looking for in WordPress.
It'll look for that database.
So now, as you did
it locally, if you
go to your project
ID [INAUDIBLE],
our [INAUDIBLE] will be hit by
this URL, which will actually
trigger it to install
WordPress in your instance.
So once you install your app,
you'll actually create a user,
and in this case, you
go to your WP admin,
and do a couple
of configurations
that are really important.
So you need to
activate a plug-in.
You need to configure
emails, and also
remember you need to hook
up your Google Cloud Storage
buckets.
So a couple of
plug-ins that are just
[INAUDIBLE] in the starter
kit that you will see,
is one, the batch manager, and
the other one is the Google App
Engine for WordPress plug-in.
So you have to activate
these two plug-ins.
The second now important thing
is configuring your email,
and also hooking up WordPress
to your Cloud Storage bucket.
So you actually see
these couple of settings.
If you go to Settings,
you'll actually
see an App Engine option.
And now you put the
App Engine email
that you want any
notification to come to.
So this really--
any notification
that affects your App Engine
app, which email do you
want it to go to?
This is usually the person
maintaining this application.
And the bucket name.
Remember we created
an instance, so we
created a bucket name
called WordPress on GAE.
So remember, this thing
is very important,
and you need to put it there.
Yeah.
So actually, that's it.
If you do that,
oh my God, you'll
have a new world hitting
you on your screen
and you'll have successfully
deployed your WordPress
on Google App Engine.
There are a couple
of tricks and tips
that you actually
need to know if you're
doing this on a very big,
robust WordPress site.
Remember, you need to change
update themes and plug-ins,
because that's the
magic of WordPress.
And the beauty about
this is you have
to maintain a local
version of the app
so that you'll be able to
maintain themes and plug-ins.
The reason because of
this is because remember,
you cannot upload onto Google
App Engine's file system.
So you can upload
to your file system
and then do a redeployment.
So each time you do
a version, and you
want to reinstall a new theme,
you just install it locally
and then do a redeployment.
And also to update
a theme, you do--
reinstall the theme
or the plug-in locally
and then do a redeployment.
So in that case, you won't
have to-- you'll actually
be able to have these plug-ins
and themes on your WordPress
instance only.
I think that's it.
Thank you very much.
Back to you, Johan.
HIREN PATEL: Cool.
Thanks Kenneth.
Thanks for that walkthrough.
It was quite interesting.
JOHANNDU TOIT: Thank you.
HIREN PATEL: So we're looking
at a couple of questions
in the Q&A session.
Again, if you have questions
and you're watching this online,
just pop them in for us.
I'll start it out
with one question.
So a lot of developers that
deploy their stacks on PHP
frameworks like the freedom
to edit their php.ini
config so that they can
control their runtime better.
App Engine is a
Platform as a Service,
but does it offer the ability
to change the runtime using
php.ini as well?
KENNETH KINYANJUI:
So it actually works
in the same concept.
Remember where I mentioned that
to update a theme or a plug-in,
we need to not do it online
but actually do it locally.
So you actually have
the php.ini file
that's actually stored locally
within your-- in the startup
kit.
So let's say you want to control
the limit of applications--
the size of files that
you want to upload.
You can go to your php.ini file,
edit it, and actually upload
it.
But if you want
to configure more
intricacies of the
runtime, you'll
not focus on the php.ini file.
What you'd actually
be dealing with mostly
is the app.yatml file,
which actually configures
your runtime for App Engine.
HIREN PATEL: Cool, thanks.
That makes sense.
The next question is, so
within the developer's console
on the Google Cloud
platform, I've
seen the Google
Cloud [INAUDIBLE]
launch for WordPress.
What is the difference
between that and this?
KENNETH KINYANJUI: So
remember how I told you
that sometimes some
developers want to control how
their architecture is running?
It's just sometimes
easier to-- some people
choose the option of either
launching in the launcher,
but you don't
actually have control
and you don't know what's
happening in the background.
So some people like to get
their hands dirty sometimes
and get to know the whole
process so that if anything
comes about, they
are going to fix it,
because they are the ones
who did the deployment.
But once you have that launcher,
for example, let's say I need
[INAUDIBLE] and you didn't
know where to start,
so you have to, you know, find
maybe someone who's an expert
and actually come
and debug it for you.
But if you actually
did it on your own,
you actually know
how to manage it.
So it's either you can
[INAUDIBLE] either of the two.
Depends on the use case.
HIREN PATEL: Cool, thanks a lot.
So we have a question from
someone on the Hangout On Air.
Being a developer, I am fond of
J-E-K-Y-L-L. I'm not too sure.
JOHANNDU TOIT: Jekyll.
HIREN PATEL: Jekyll.
It's this framework.
Can you deploy Jekyll
to Google App Engine?
KENNETH KINYANJUI:
Oh, Gentoo, Gentoo.
Does he mean Gentoo?
G-E-N-double-T-O?
JOHANNDU TOIT: If I can
pop something in here.
Jekyll, if I remember correctly,
is a static site generator.
KENNETH KINYANJUI: Oh, Jekyll.
JOHANNDU TOIT:
Probably be better
to pop that on Cloud Storage
instead of App Engine.
[INAUDIBLE] and discuss, and
we'll send it out to Community
and let them know how to do it.
KENNETH KINYANJUI: Yeah.
I think it's actually possible
to deploy Jekyll on Google App
Engine, but it actually-- it
will be better to do it-- no,
no-- since it's--
depending on-- OK.
That's a bit tricky.
We can actually debate on that.
But I do know that's you can
deploy a static site on Google
App Engine just using Python,
[INAUDIBLE] having the Python
[INAUDIBLE].
But I think Jekyll runs
in [INAUDIBLE], so I'm not
really sure on that.
But you know, it's
something that you
can debate on the Community.
HIREN PATEL: Cool.
JOHANNDU TOIT: We've got
a few more questions,
but we're running
out of time a bit,
so we're going to have to cut
it a little bit short there.
But Kenneth is in the G+
community, so ping him.
Tell him what does work
and what doesn't work,
and please post what you find.
So just thank you for tuning in.
You might know or
not know there's
a Google Developers Africa
group that you can go join.
And we post all these updates,
all the status updates,
all that sort of thing.
And then we'll be
posting feedback links
so you can give
us some feedback,
either from [INAUDIBLE].
And you can actually apply to
be on the show if you want.
So like we spotlighted Mercy,
if you've got something cool
or you're doing something
awesome, please ping us
and we'll get you on the
show and you can tell
everyone what you're doing.
Thank you for tuning in.
See you next time.
Bye-bye.
HIREN PATEL: Cheers.
KENNETH KINYANJUI: Bye.